each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay the focus of this war is the
representation the semantic
representation of streams by that I mean
taking extremes and the content and
basically right writing them down in rdf
keeping all the important information
that the we want about this thing but
also doing doing so in a way that the
this thing will be easily accessible by
x a.d.f tools and the field question is
why why would we want to do that but
using rdf to represent streams in
instances if the the benefits are i
think obviously idea it is a flexible
self-describing way of describing data
and lincoln linking it to the metadata
the second question is who i would that
be a problem after all rdf is is a model
that was created supposedly to say
anything about anything so in principle
to dec just write write an ontology 44
experience but as it happens writing a
there are certain scenes in rdf done
when once that you try your data only
that like that it's not it's not easy to
oh it's not efficient to query this data
and one of this case in particular is is
anything that has to do with time since
rdf doesn't it doesn't take time into
into account so in particular there is
no concept of time or data changing over
time
so we try to provide in this in these
words it's a model for an RDF base model
for streams that provides an asteroid
representation of streams so the ones
that you have your streams represented
in in this way you can easily exchange
or you could you can easily use these
streams in different seasons so creates
an interoperability between systems that
use streams and it does so in a way that
is independent of the actual content of
this team whether it is numeric data or
text data or images so basically it's an
ominous student of string of stream data
and dice that uses RDF so you can reuse
any ldf tools that you have to for your
data so you could query your data soon
RDF quad engines order ID prisoners so
we provide a model that attempts to
achieve this and also we provide an
implementation that is specifically
optimized for for fishing access to time
series so it's it's not an
implementation of this model based on
based on top of the IDF stores and
others some 70 managers so few
characteristics of streams that
differentiated from from our data is by
strengthening sequential data that is
possibly updated a high throughput and
that is unbounded so it's different from
from regular leasing RDF because it
doesn't have a beginning on F&M
and another important point is that when
we are talking about the streams the
data or the content of the streams is
getting updated frequently but the
metadata
we know about this dream oh where the
data is coming from state of Maine stays
the same so we don't need to know we're
talking princess upload data is coming
from from the sensor and we're going to
play the metadata about that we can
write we can have constant metadata
about the sensors that scribe book the
location of designs or other
characteristics of the sensor but the
data except that coming from the sensor
has doesn't need or done noise metadata
you once that you know that it comes
from that sensory only need to note
about time it came sort of a more formal
definition of the stream is basically at
least an unbound the leaves of pairs
where one of order person one element of
the pair is the data itself and the
second element is a timestamp and the
time start the meaning of the timestamp
for the for the data in extremis is
defined by the user so it I could be the
position in the sequence or the detail
but the data occur all the time but
there was measure there has been in the
last couple of years song a person's
incorporating time into rdf i basically
extended the idea of data model and some
of these efforts and a 11 monitor is
getting some adoption it is the multi
errors in which they essentially say
that a predicate of assertion in rdf has
a valid only for a certain time and you
mark that assertion has been valid only
during that time to the Anniston
interval i specifically for streams
they're having other terms that
essentially see rdf like a sequence of
um or incense in session in a sense you
take the the RDF class with all your
data and do partition it in several
sugah what is soo graph is valid is the
data that is valued at a certain point
in time and dozen other words well when
you only interesting in in a window of
data in time so you only need to know
how what assertions were valid in a
certain interval but it by partitioning
insu graph you're also breaking the
dependencies of things that work buddies
at different times and essentially
things that 44 in different sub graph
now you have no way to know the dinner
you later or model is Zion specific for
four streams so I think it can can do
better than the model that is deanna for
for time and it's based on not that not
same at which time an assertion is valid
but consider the resources change over
time so it's actually resources a state
and you can talk about resources about
time stamping the resource itself
instead of the app instead of the
assertions that you make very and since
resources in practice this is also
associated with data and you can see
this this data changing over time and so
you can easily integrate used Einstein
with the resources serves you can
incinerate linked data and demented data
so here's an example of what what the
model looks like this would be data in
regular they're indicating that there's
a sensor in Chicago that measures
temperate the temperature of the day at
us
each day and you could represent you
could represent that in rdf easy enough
but when you want to query this data
you're gonna have some problems that I'm
gonna explain later sign our model you
would annotate the resource saying this
is the state of the sensor at this
particular day and the that when the
sensor had that particular state does
table described at these properties so
this is not only a syntax no it's not
just syntactic sugar this although you
could have translate is written these
two this is actually a different model
the city resources have asked us state
and you can only time stamp the subject
of a search and you could text on the
object so you could say it's it's nice
to finance ample example about that but
you decided if the value of a certain
property was d was was not only a result
of what was the particular state of
resource in a particular time so that
this one happens to be compatible with
regular DF you can translate between the
two using an ontology but you can also
they are semantically equivalent in the
sense that whatever you can be faring
one model you can infer in the in the
other model so the inferences or are
consistent as long as the the ideology
of standard EF with interval logic or a
subset of interval logic and I said you
can translate it to in RDF and
determinated RDF work or new idea of
North using an ontology so his his a
subscription of the ontology
well this is that you should notice is
that you can timestamp resources using
either an Eastern or an interval or
audio cerebral ordinal that represents
the deposition of the resource in the
off position the position of this Toyota
result in these sequence so here's a one
example of how data looks in this model
and this this this v-22 or model one RDF
love it too to IDF and essentially what
we're saying is that the this resource
that has several states and you can
provide you can make assertions about
the the resource in that state but you
can also make a serious about the
resource in general saying and that we
do the equivalent to say to say that
this assertion is true for for the
resources at all times now he has had
the data will loop translated into into
level RDF and this tour r AQ equivalent
assuming you have interval assuming you
have interval logic an idea so some
properties of this knowledge that you
can as i said before the these streams
can have can contain arbitrary data and
there's no the there's not a play fine
frequency for for de for the rate at
which data pearson streams now these are
not there is a beginning and end point
so on top of this model we also provide
a query language talk to us as easy to
quality dating this new model and we
provided that that language as an
extension of part one so liberal Sparkle
is as we know the ED language to query
this standard language to query rdf now
he's using DD ontology to translate data
from from 2 to level rdf in regular
sparkle this is how acquired with the 22
to ask for the current off for the last
imperatore at chicago at the last
competitor here means the last
temperature we know of because this
string is not supposed to lava and then
and this this party looks fairly
complicated but although you could use a
different ontology to to add to make a
simple query st. data or you could
rewrite this query and make a little
simpler deployments that too since the
stem is unbounded to note what is the
last point in it you have to essentially
scan it and see which point doesn't have
a point a data point after it which is a
fairly expensive operation so in in in
in the version longest in the stench of
purgatory that we provide the queries is
not only simpler syntactically but this
time annotation here has a special
semantics that the query native to use
to know that the data could be index
using the time stan and that you could
use that index to answer this query
quickly instead of scanning the whole
data
now we implemented this in top of tupelo
there's going to be a presentation over
to blood tomorrow so i won't talk much
of this but tupelo is essentially to rdf
but about jdbc to is to relational
databases is a family provides an
extraction to access different
superstore and two different
repositories 000 different semantic
repositories and the interesting the
nice thing about these implementations
that tuple doesn't understand this new
idea to block words with regular at the
earth but is easier now to to
conceptually translate between art
regularity f and tamanna teta idea on
the fly that you can simply put a layer
on top of tupelo and provide time
annotated rdf also or assisting
integrate with other with typical stream
manages where i will talk about later so
but I was talking enough that one
creditor of streams it is a
high-throughput direct data conn high
rate and there's systems that are the
season the science is beautiful 408 in
real time and and and super stores don't
usually work well with data that speed
so with we provide a bridge between
triple stores over rdf and string
managers like open source data tooling
that allows you to simply fetch or
publish your data using these systems
that are real time i still keep your
data in rdf and quality data later in
our dear we also provide integration
with fully subscribe systems right JM
like java message system the that allows
you to you to do our Foolish subscribe
communication so you can you can do
basically a band based queries over
there a little earlier streams i'm going
to skip this one one application one
example application of me has deploy
using this system is the it's based on
puter sensors and wear it with this this
about is that we have data coming from
from sensors radar data then is emails
from from driver at reflectivity of
magenta and that does a stream that we
face using this system and we process
this data and police
in this case is the reigning bull
basically this this beta H process and
the results are published as a stream
and they are available in this case and
as XML but you could have have the
available as RDF or some other form so
to reiterate we provide a molecule
represent of trains that is compatible
with RDF to circumstance and as a syntax
for this model and a query language to
then it does include nice but they're
include somatic queries expanded with
with x semantics
okay yes the time stan is that there is
you put the test time in the resource
and the resources is peace whatever your
data is so we're saying is that in this
case this sensor is a resource and when
do you think of the the timestamp sensor
is the stay of these sensory DS fun in
time so that will be the dimension of
this sensor now the ontology is used to
translate this model into regular DF so
if you want to spread rdf doesn't have
the time stamps so if you want to
suppress this deranged lever idea you
could use the ontology you could
translate it totally abusing the
ontology so you can't represent the same
thing that you would lose some of the
advantage of the model which are DD
incense dude your query engine when
you're putting this data would need to
know that this ontology have some
special semantics that you can use to
index the data
okay let me ask you stupid why not just
store the data as we come from the
sensors why go through this complicated
transformation well you because when to
represent the data in semantically with
women but only the data we want data
with semantic markup say take the last
two hours of data basically at the
workflow if it's meant for the exam one
last Johnson we have and therefore we
had to take extremely data put it in
something that we in the workflow asking
other semantic questions whether one
place you could ask
what it needs in terms of time series
and pull the right get out so that this
is a pattern but I think we've got lots
of places where there since you're
streaming stuff in and you want to ask
Melissa up workflows that just work on
not giving these files and let me figure
out I really what I'm talking to her
name you on what the last two hours or
what the sort of stuff so that that's
the problem air china solvents 44.com
battles wondering when you need to time
and not also a location maybe sensors
not the one scenario i think you know
but you know at first that's another
point talk about is that nobody what
I've got to say find me the sensors in
Illinois or in this area and really what
you want to store it triple levels
some big city between your index and do
the same kind of trick that's